when you are in the position of
deploying capital you have to understand
how to separate the sort of hype from
the reality and like the actual reality
on the ground
of these kinds of businesses right
you're looking to back
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders we have with us today
saloni bojuani investor
founders factory saloni is an investor
at founders factory where she leads
investments across both consumer and b2b
formerly she was strategy consultant and
more recently worked at uber and expedia
saloni has been angel investing for
three years is a part of backed vc's
community
alma angels and january ventures
operator network
most recently saloni co-founded sea
ventures aiming to close the gender
funding gap in the venture capital
ecosystem
saloni bojwani thank you for joining me
on 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm well how about you i'm i'm doing
great thank you and you're calling from
england right now right yeah i'm uh i'm
based in london
wonderful so you know you deal a lot
with strategy a lot of investing
and the gender gaps but but what i
really want to pick your brain over
these 20 minutes is is really who you
are as a person and
and how you came to understand that this
is really what you want to do
and then also some of your outlook as to
the industry and what's actually
happening and what you're observing
so perhaps you can even take me back all
the way to your time at cnbc
uh powdering up you know the upcoming
guests so
you know you want to be journalist and
and so what is that passion about and
then how do you
translate that more to the different
positions you've had
sure so i actually i mean i'm originally
from singapore that's where i grew up
um and i went to tufts
in uh outside of boston for my undergrad
um and there i sort of i started getting
into
photojournalism i did a lot of sort of
um extracurricular courses um
with a couple of the sort of centers on
campus they have a bunch of different
stuff going on there and i really
enjoyed
that work um it sort of takes you out of
your
comfort zone a lot of the time to
explore like pretty
pretty gritty stuff um and so i really
enjoyed that
um i thought that you know this could be
a really good career path
um and coming from a sort of pretty
entrepreneurial
pretty driven family um you know tiger
mom tiger dad
etc um um
i you know they were very supportive in
the beginning of of this
you know desire of mine and this
ambition um
but when i was closer to graduating
um after my cnbc internship where i was
not just collecting news clippings and
sort of
um alerts from the rss feeds but also
powdering up gas
as i as i mentioned um uh
i had a pretty realistic conversation
with my dad and he was like all right
well do you want to be homeless
because that's probably what's going to
happen if you become a photojournalist
unless you're super successful um
and i mean i was an economics major
um and international development major i
did both
um and you know none of them were sort
of
both of them were pretty pretty numerate
um pretty analytical
studies um and i also sort of
fell into the same i sort of fell into
the same trap
i would say not even trap but just the
same sort of mentality as
as the majority of my graduating class
um
of you know if you're an economics major
or anything in that
in that space you go into banking or
consulting
um and that was i think one it was
approximately one year before everybody
started wanting to go into tech
um because a lot of my friends in the in
the year below me um
saw a huge shift in in what people
wanted to do
post college um but yeah and then i
moved back to singapore for personal
reasons
um and um and started my career in
management consulting
um i did that for four years um focused
on strategy work across southeast asia
um it was super interesting super
grueling as well
um and taught me a huge amount
um and then that was actually it was
actually during one of the projects that
i did for the singapore government
in the digital media sector and mapping
it out and
understanding the growth opportunities
that i
realized there was a huge big big world
of startups and
and innovation um and you know in
indonesia and the philippines et cetera
you're seeing
huge amounts of technical innovation
technological innovation
miles ahead of of the west right like
there was
an app that we used to use while we were
in jakarta
um called clicky that was exactly like
deliveroo
um but it was way back when um you know
when i landed
on a monday morning and i'd forgotten my
laptop charger my colleagues from the
jakarta office would
order a charger on instagram and it
would
arrive in 30 minutes wow yeah so like it
was it was explained that by the way you
know how do you explain this discrepancy
so i think you know um that region of
the world is full of early adopters when
it comes to tech
um so you know my parents are super tech
savvy my dad
has more apps on his phone than i do um
and i think it's the it's the region of
the world that i think
skipped over having um like
having desktop first tendencies and went
straight to mobile first
and so it just is like a very techy
savvy
place um or area and geography
and so um you see that all the time with
you know i mean
with china it's the same thing right
like wechat was
more more capable of doing more things
before
whatsapp even was it was a company um
so i think it's just a very different
mentality in that part of the world and
then
i knew i wanted to go to business school
i didn't want to really go back to the
us
so i applied to london business school
knowing that london was somewhere that i
knew i could settle long term um
and um you know i i took my gmat in like
10 days and and
you know did the whole process in a very
rushed manner as you do
yeah when you're in consulting and you
have any time off
um but yeah and then and then yeah then
i moved to london
in august of 2015 or july of 2015 i
should say
so yeah and i've been there i've been
here ever since um
i started um you know i did my mba
during that time i worked at companies
like uber and expedia
i also wanted to try out being on the
sort of buy side or investment side
um so i worked also at a fund called
that's now called luminous ventures it
was called um
it was part of a larger family office
fund and
um and got exposure to the sort of early
stage vc ecosystem
um and after that joined the founding
team of a company
called zebra fuel funded by local globe
enforcement capital
grew that from four to 47 people um
raised two rounds of funding and then
moved over to the investor side finally
um but i know you mentioned
that made you attracted to that so why
why make that shift
so i had actually while i was at zebra
and actually during my mba had been
working
and advising pre-seed companies um on
their fundraising strategy their
business and
and go to market strategy you know
things like the
the things also that are that are sort
of bread and butter of consulting
um so market sizing etc um
to understand how how best to optimize
their business
um for their north star metrics um
and i really enjoyed that work i started
writing
very small angel checks into some of the
businesses and founders that i that i
really enjoyed working with and that i
trusted
um and then i realized that there was
also a huge
um gender funding gap um and
[Music]
you know the numbers were sort of not
moving or they were moving in the wrong
direction
they still have been um and that there
is a huge amount that can be done
or there's a huge amount that needs to
be done to sort of
address that um so i've refined my my
personal investment thesis
accordingly to focus on female-led
businesses
and um and then you know i really
enjoyed that
i really enjoy looking at multiple
different businesses in a given
area or space um understanding what
would work and what doesn't
hypothesizing even over it because who
really knows at that stage right
um but you know finding the proof points
um
and so yeah so there's a lot i don't
like about the venture ecosystem but i
think that
there is a lot that i do like about it
and that i think if you think about it
in a responsible way
um and you understand that you know
deploying capital is a huge amount of
power
in terms of how the world will look or
determining how the world will look
um post-investment um then it can be
really powerful
and it can be a really and it's also
really let's be real it's a really fun
job right
um you know like me so what is the fun
part of it so
what what gets you so excited about it i
think that the learning curve right
like i think you you have to skill
yourself up really quickly
on new technologies on different ways of
looking at the same problem
um at all the different innovations um
you learn so much through that process
and i think that's i mean that really
like
that really drives me um i think most
investors
are similar and that otherwise they
probably wouldn't be in their profession
um
so yeah so i think that's a really fun
part i think you know working alongside
entrepreneurs adding value to their to
their business and to their
sort of journey is also really rewarding
um
that really like is what will get me up
in the morning
um and i think you know that's super
rewarding
so so yeah and so you mentioned a little
bit about this idea of responsible
venture and so what does that actually
you know entail for you what does it
mean to
to act responsibly in this eventual
world
so i think um when so i mean i'll use
some examples here right but
i think ultimately it's when you are in
the position of deploying capital
you have to understand how to separate
the sort of hype from the reality and
like the actual reality on the ground
of these kinds of businesses right
you're looking to back
um so there's you know i actually i read
a book actually
um called smoke and mirrors um by
actually someone who's who's quite a
good friend um gemma milne
and it's sort of each chapter goes
through like
what people think is the case with
certain sectors like agritac which is
quite like a black box for most people
um energy um and renewables
um you know space tech for these things
and like what's the reality and what's
the hype telling you
and so i think investors or anybody in
the position of deploying capital
and backing an industry or or a thesis
really
um is in the position of having to
really understand what
are the dynamics in that market that you
should be taking into consideration
um and the way that i like and the way
that this sort of plays out
right is um for example
um we've seen like the the huge
explosion in grocery delivery
right in in europe and and the world
right like with deja with weezy with all
of these guys
and you know when dja went out i'm
really close with with a lot of them and
i have friends that work with a lot of
these companies and
um you know they raised diesel raised 20
million right off the bat
um in their seed round um which
i mean is is now becoming more the norm
um scarily so but
but it's it's still a big seed round
right in europe
and sorry i mean europe i mean the uk
and europe
um i'm still not over clearly
but um but i think when
investors make that kind of decision
they're making an executive decision
that this kind of service absolutely has
to exist in the world
right that's why they're going to throw
money at it um
and so i think when you think about like
backing a company or an industry or a
service
you're really thinking or you should be
thinking like this has to exist
right because it's going to make the
world and it's going to make consumers
and it's going to make businesses
better and better off right and so
that's what i
that's how i sort of think about the the
process of deploying capital into a
company
um and so when you're looking at the
gender gap specifically
you mentioned a few times and this is
also something that you're that you're
thinking about a lot so
so give me the breakdown especially you
know in the in the
european uk market which i don't know uh
too much about
what is what is happening there and what
what are you in that sort of ecosystem
in regards to this idea of gender gap
sure so i
um i actually with two two co-founders
launched a capital raising platform for
female founders
or female-led businesses rather and
the sort of the premise on which we we
built this is
um there is a huge funding gap
it's it's now it's 1.7 of venture
capital funding
in the european the uk and europe goes
to female ed businesses
that's down from two point four percent
four years ago
um 2.4 was pretty abysmal to begin with
and it's actually been going down
um and i think you know covet 19 has
also exacerbated
as you probably know um the the problems
for women
right having to take on the burden of of
you know the household chores and
homeschooling and all of that
caring for the elderly etc um that's
been an additional
and an incremental burden on them that
has has
sort of worsened that gap um
and so um when we look at
you know the the initiatives in the
ecosystem there's you know there's a
huge amount of initiatives and
people want to make change um
but those initiatives are you know they
might be moving the needle a little bit
but not enough
um and so you know the three of us
nicole trin and i have actually been
you know doing this for a couple of
years now working alongside
a female founder or a couple of female
founders to help them close up their
fundraise
make sure that they're in touch with the
right investors make sure they have the
right access
um make sure they're structuring their
round in the correct way etc all of
these things
um that are not always you know
accessible
to to e to every founder right um and
how do you
so what is the biggest challenge that
you're observing you know if you had to
to to you know converge on on some
specific challenges that are
causing this gap right now i'm hearing
on one hand this
this idea that female founders perhaps
have a more difficult time closing their
rounds or understanding exactly how to
structure is that because there's
they're not getting enough attention
they're not getting enough assistance or
enough support
from big funds what is actually you know
the gap that you're observing
yeah so i think the the gap is actually
in the early stage right so
we actually surveyed um a bunch of seed
and series a funds
and even beyond um to ask why there is
such a lack of diversity in their
portfolio
and they all said that it's a pipeline
problem so there's not enough pre-seed
stage and see
an early seed stage businesses that are
led by females or co-founded by females
that are getting the appropriate amount
of funding to come
up that pipeline and go up the food
chain so to speak
um and so the gap that we're trying to
fix or to address
is to let's take all of these pre-seed
stage and you know some some of them are
seed some of them are even series a
but let's get them you know to a have a
community of like-minded
over-achieving individuals who often
experience similar problems so they can
bounce ideas around
um with each other and you know have a
community around that
but b let's get them in front of the
right investors and let's
also pick investors that we know in the
ecosystem
are um are you know mission driven and
mission aligned
to work with these with these founders
um you know in the sector and stage that
they're familiar with and that they
invest in
to actually help them open up their own
networks the same way that if my best
friend from lbs was founding a company
i would help her like navigate the
entire ecosystem
um so that's the sort of rapport that
we're trying to build is or
to cultivate between the investor
mentors and the founders
um and so far it's going really well
i mean a lot of them are already closing
up their rounds or have identified their
lead
um and you know so i think
bit by bit we can actually hopefully
move the needle in a meaningful way
no i think that's a it's a great outlook
and i think that the way that you're
they're actually tangibly going in and
and helping you know hands-on
is something that is not uh is not
trivial and you know a lot of people are
talking about
the gender gap and venture but not not a
lot of people are actually going in and
and are being hands-on about it and so i
think that i think there's a lot of
inspiration to be taken from here
and i want to thank you again for coming
on and sharing with me your your
personal journey your personal passions
i really appreciate it
are you ready for some fun questions
sure
all right so we'll start off easy we'll
get a little bit harder as we go along
and number one what was your favorite
subject in school
um so my favorite subject like changed a
lot to be fair um
it started as english my spelling and
grammar is
to uh to a level that is that is
unparalleled i would say
um because of my parents sticklerishness
um in that realm so english was
definitely for the majority of my
schooling my favorite subject i also
really loved history
i really liked physics and i really
liked wow apology
yeah i'm really really cool i'm
constantly surprised that so many
investors on the show enjoyed history or
enjoyed the humanities you know back in
school so i think that
at some point somebody should do a
little bit of research as to why exactly
that is
and i'm personally a math guy and the
second question i for you is one of your
role models
real or fake throughout your career
throughout my career
um throughout my career uh
honestly probably a mix of my mother and
my sister
um so my older sister um
she is by far and away one of the most
intelligent
humans i've ever met she also went to
stanford by the way
um and she is like a genius and she
would absolutely murder me for saying
this
um but um i think
the rigor with which she analyzes
situations and problems is really
admirable and you know when i when i ask
her
a question if i'm having trouble with it
it's always it always seems seems super
simple
when she sort of unpacks it for me um
and i think you know she's definitely
someone that has been a role model
to me throughout my upbringing and my
career
um and my mom just because
she's my mom and i think she's like
amazing
uh as a human just like strength wise
and resilience wise
very very cool i love that and i have
the the weirdest question
it's not the most important but it's
definitely the weirdest three words you
would choose to describe yourself
um i think uh
one would probably be direct or
transparent
um i'm not one speed around the bush i'm
quite direct um as you've probably
gleaned from this 20-minute phone call
um definitely and then i think
the second is um resilient or gritty
um so i don't really shy away from
from like challenge and hard work um
and i think that's been a good thing but
is maybe
maybe a little bit stupid sometimes um
in terms of
becoming stubborn but but yeah and then
the third would probably be um i'm
unsuspectingly
introverted um wow
yeah i would not guess that yeah like
i'm i'm quite a hermit um
and you know i'm one of the people that
really quite enjoyed some parts of
lockdown
um because it allowed me to just like be
be at home with my book
um so yeah
well i i'm surprised by some of the
words not all of them but saloni thank
you so much for coming and sharing with
me your story
and thank you for you know the hands-on
work that you're doing and i i love
hearing people's journeys as they
transition from you know the transition
throughout their career and
and are open to exploring their passions
and then helping others achieve those
passions so thank you very much
yeah and all i can say left is stay safe
and stay healthy
you too thank you for having me
thank you bye